countries are in the grip of an energy
crisis with gas prices up 300 percent
since the outbreak of war in Ukraine and
EU leaders are still gripped by
indecision over how to deal with it this
road map that now has to be worked on
and then implemented it is a joint
purchase big step forward it is the
rules for sharing gas so the solidarity
agreements and the rules that have to be
followed in case of a severe disruption
it is the topic of excessive price
prices and how to limit them
despite hints at agreement division
remains between heavyweights Germany and
France on an energy price cap that would
see the EU refusing to trade gas above a
certain level Germany believes that
would lead to supply shortages with
Traders simply selling their Wares on
Asian markets for a higher price they've
agreed to keep talking
in classic EU style the leaders have
pushed discussions onto energy ministers
who'll meet next week ahead of a
possible emergency Summit next month it
seems likely they'll agree to some form
of cartel style gas buying similar to
the methods used to buy vaccines during
the pandemic it is less certain to what
extent they may agree on a price cap
foreign
substantial time was given to Ukraine
itself ways of helping to protect its
energy infrastructure the target of
repeated Russian attack
Ukraine's President Vladimir zielinski
addressed the leaders via video link he
warned that Russia was planning further
attacks on energy hubs in particular a
hydroelectric dam in the south
if the Russian terrorists blow out this
Dam more than 80 settlements including
her song will face rapid flooding
hundreds of thousands of people could be
affected
ahead of a freezing winter he warned
part of Russia's plan is to set off
another wave of migration towards the EU
Jonah Al Jazeera Brussels